administration's response to the
coronavirus a government scientist who
was removed from his job
is speaking out and claims he was pushed
out for raising alarms about just how
poor the u.s response was
to covet 19. this comes as president
trump refuses to wear a mask
and as another white house staffer test
positive for the coronavirus
nicole killian is at the white house
this morning nicole what's the latest
well there's a lot happening here at the
white house and michelle the
commissioner of the food and drug
administration is now
self-quarantining after coming into
contact with someone who tested positive
for covid19
the white house says it's testing
staffers daily who are in close
proximity
to the president and vice president
while the president says
he thinks the virus will go away even
without a vaccine
cbs news has learned the personal
assistant of ivanka trump is among the
latest to test positive for coronavirus
this after the vice president's press
secretary katie miller was diagnosed
she thanked well-wishers friday night
tweeting i'm doing well and look forward
to getting back to work for the american
people
she's a wonderful young woman and today
she tested positive
she hasn't come into contact with me
miller is the wife of senior
presidential adviser
stephen miller earlier this week a
member of the president's personal
military valet
also tested positive the white house
insisted
taking precautions but the vice
president did not wear a mask during a
trip to iowa
the president didn't wear one either at
a washington ceremony for world war ii
veterans
the wind was blowing so hard in such a
direction that if
if the plague ever reached them might be
very surprised third we need to conduct
clinical trials after raising red flags
about the administration's pandemic
response
whistleblower dr rick bride spoke for
the first time to 60 minutes
the former vaccine official claims he
was removed from his job for putting
science over
politics friday a federal watchdog
recommended he be reinstated
i'm the director of barda to take me out
of our organization
focused on drugs and vaccines and
diagnostics
in the middle of a pandemic the worst
public health crisis that our country
has faced in a century
and decapitate the barta organization
to move me over to a very small
focused project of any scale of any
level importance
is not responsible didn't make sense
this week the government started
shipping rem desevere but concerns have
emerged that the drug cleared for
emergency use in covid patients
has been slowed to reach some hospitals
right now i think there's a lot of
confusion
of how to distribute it
fema says the drug has been sent out to
seven states but the next round will be
handled by the department of health and
human services the white house
says that task force member dr debra
burks will also help to coordinate
distribution
back to you dana all right nicole
killian thank you
in other news magician roy horn one half